alright cool so yeah I'm Thomas French
with my colleague Fred Ferrell I'm the
CTO at San table and Fred's of data
scientist so just to give you a little
bit get very quick background sound
table where data science company we
specialize in agent-based modeling it
was first commercial projects in 2009
and we're currently since last summer
we're fifty percent owned by dunnhumby
so dunnhumby is a majority owned by
Tesco and they their asset is kind of
the loyalty card data so we've been
working to build models off that
consumer models and I'll talk a bit
about that as well so other people that
we work with in the public sector
projects with public health England we
work with the Cabinet Office and we've
done projects say with Tesco and people
like coca-cola as well okay so quickly
I'll give an introduction kind of
overview what agent-based modeling is
then we'll talk about Fred's going to
talk about some work we've been doing
modeling the London riots 2011 and then
I'll give you a quick kind of touch on
kinetic data science platform that we're
building to support this work ok so
wider context we live in an increasingly
complex and dynamic world you know the
technology side we've got increasing
computing power it's cheaper available
by things you know technology such as
the cloud and of course I mean we're all
here we all know this more and more data
is being collected find a finer levels
of granularity etc so you know we
believe if we can understand the world
we can make better decisions about
better planning and allocate resources
and this type of thing so I like to cook
the quote from young storica professor
Berkeley it's also the professor behind
spark and maize us so the data is only
as valuable as the decisions that
enables right I'm sure you kind of all
understand that so I wanted to give you
a quick kind of stove review of the type
of questions that we kind of you know
questions that get asked of us and the
type of stuff that we're interested in
modeling and using agent-based modeling
for so we like to say that we focus more
on kind of strategic level questions
rather than tactical solutions so
interested in things like how we're
changing attitudes towards health you
know impacting the sales of soft drinks
how do people respond and how can we you
know how do we understand how they
respond to things like advertising why
and how do people quit smoking so that's
the project we're working with public
health England you know how
sexual transmitted diseases spread
through social networks and how do we
get people to wash their hands more
places like India so that's another
project that we've we've worked on so
what we're interested in here within
this wider context is behavior change
okay so what is agent-based modeling
well it's a modeling technique as the
clues in the name so we build
representations of real systems of real
we're trying to model real phenomena it
has its roots in complexity science
Quebec City system so people are
interested in studying kind of
biological systems complex adaptive
systems particularly gets bandied around
quite a lot but the notion of emergence
so what executives emergence need so the
idea here in complexity science is that
they're interested in a macro level you
might get these sort of complex
behaviors but actually underneath it the
micro level you've got very simple rules
of behavior so through these
interactions and through these simple
rules get this emergence of kind of more
complex behavior we use it particularly
interested in behavioral modeling so
understanding kind of modeling human
behavior and kind of thinking about why
people do what they do and how we can
influence that and be in your behavior
change so really we talked about we're
building hypothesis of behavior and of
course true to its roots you know we do
this bottom-up so we model so I'll talk
I'll give more you know more detail on
this but really we're talking about
building these systems bottom-up so
giving identifying the kind of basic
entities in our case would be humans and
individuals and thinking about simple
rules of behavior simple rules that
guide them and then observing that and
observing what happens at a more macro
macro level so oh it's a bit abstract
I'll I'll give some give some examples
of that and we also find that you know
the interesting thing about the
bottom-up is it's quite an accessible
metaphor so as an approach to modeling
you know people can intuitively
understand and kind of see you know
understand more about what's going on in
this town was going on inside so here is
a quite a was playful but sort of view
of what is an agent-based model so the
basic entities in it are the agents
they're situated in an environment in
our case you know we tend to work in
computer kind of simulations virtual
environments so the agents have situated
in this environment and they have rules
of behavior and we give them attitudes
and attributes so for example attribute
would be some kind of demographic and a
and then attitudes would be you know
their beliefs about the world what they
believe to be true and what they how
they act and of course they interact
with each other and they interact with
their environment as well but for us I
mean we work with dental well in terms
of the physical kind of environment you
know that could be a kind of Geo
geographical space or it could be kind
of a social network so we've tended to
look at kind of social network stuff
more than geographical ok so I thought
I'd give you an example of kind of the
classic kind of old-school agent-based
model so in the 1970s Nobel
prize-winning economist Thomas Schelling
in the United States was interested in
racial segregation and how this was how
this was emerging and he was
particularly interested in how
individual preferences could lead to
this you know this kind of macro
phenomena so he built upon I think I was
on an airplane he decided to do this and
part of the reason we like showing this
is because there's actually not a
computational ABM it's you know his
visit has a physical kind of
manifestation so what he what he decided
to do was to build this model is he said
look I've got these individuals I'm
going to place them randomly on a grid
I'm going to tap there's going to be two
types of agents and they are going to
have what we call some measure of
sameness of whether they're happy so the
idea was they look at their immediate
neighbors and given some threshold they
decide whether they're happy or not with
that and if they're not happy they move
okay so a very simple rule of behavior
is they look at their environment and
they judge whether they're happy or not
given some threshold and if they're not
happy then they move and if they are
happy they stay okay so it's very simple
you either they're either happy or
unhappy if they're unhappy they move to
random location and if they're happy
they stay okay so we thought as a
tribute to shelling we thought we would
do this with a stopgap kind of video so
we took a grid we took two peas and
Tempe coins we place them randomly on
the grid and then we applied this rule
of behavior manually and then you can
see so you can see what happens oops
sorry should play okay so over time
we're judging the coins and saying are
they happy or not they're not happy
we're randomly moving and you'll see as
it evolves
get the segregation emerging
so of course it converges so there are
some rules about that but yeah it you
know in general be set up the right way
it will converge and then you'll get
this you'll get the same state so I mean
in some level it wasn't particularly
surprising right if people are not happy
they're going to move they're going to
segregate but the what the thing the
interesting insight that shelling had
was that actually individuals have a
high tolerance for other types you can
still get this macro level behavior so
that was interesting so even when kind
of at the lower level people are
actually quite tolerant of others emerge
it emerges that you can get this sort of
segregation so that was quite
interesting right because I guess people
the time would have assumed that that
would own you know even if people people
weren't tolerant or you wouldn't yeah so
okay so how do we derive these rules of
behavior well it will you know will
depend on what's available will depend
on the project but generally we will
speak to the domain experts we talked to
people who know the behavior of the
target kind of group of the agents to
talk to them and extract kind of rules
of behavior and increasing in complexity
you know then if you know we'll use
survey data as well so what people kind
of report on their own behavior and
their own attitudes and will you know
will also when we have access we'll use
behavioral data so individual level data
we can extract rules from that to see
what people do you know what they buy
and what p.m. what they actually do
rather than necessarily what the report
they do and then finally you know we've
started using things techniques on
supervised machine learning techniques
to help us extractor alls from larger
data sets more complex data sex and what
higher-dimensional okay so how do we
actually build these things so when we
started the first abms were built in
kind of well-known development
environment canelo go open source and
that was sort of the original models and
that allows you to quit kind of
prototype quickly prototype in a way and
it's got widgets and it's quite nice but
we moved on quite relatively quickly
onto another package called repast which
is again open source c++ give you nice
scale you can run lots of model lots of
simulations and then we move to a hybrid
and eventually we wrote our own kind of
lightweight ABM package and that was
really because well you know the cost of
getting going on C++ it could give us
scale but it couldn't give us the
agility so you know hence we
pi data we're big fans of Python so
we've built this library browsers to
quickly prototype to stay agile with it
and of course we have access to the to
the wonderful ecosystem around around PI
data and then to support that we wrote a
cluster framework that allows us to
spawn up in the cloud in easy to launch
lots of instances to run large-scale
simulations to calibrate and explore the
models so just to give you a quick quick
sense of what it actually would look
like so here's a typical kind of a BM
algorithm in pseudocode ish so of course
we read in reading some time series
about the environment we've got we read
in the agents the attributes and how
their place within social network and
then we have what we call the two loops
so the simulation loop over time and
then the inner loop for the agents and
here we're taking again so reading
inputs in processing messages perhaps
from social network making decisions
about that and then sending messages out
over social network so that would give
you some idea okay so of course the big
question is how do you that's all well
and good you can build a model about
anything how do you actually you know
how do you actually validate it so this
is you know this is a bit I'm being a
bit cheeky here of course because in our
world you know it's a model ever
validated I mean it will always it's by
definition some ways an approximation of
the real system so you know it is and as
george box famously said all models are
wrong some are useful so how do we how
do we do it well depending again
depending on the case depending how much
data there is I mean we will look you
know initially there will be a certain
amount of visual validation or be
looking for types of behavior will be
looking for trends trying to say does
this you know fit with our own intuition
our own understanding of the world and
then moving down to more detailed kind
of analysis so if there's data available
you know will be yeah both of the micro
and macro levels validating individual
based models using multiple data sets of
course we can validating against
reference data and you know of course
using training and testing splitting up
the data sets when appropriate okay so
that's a pretty quick tour so I'm going
to hand over to Fred who's going to talk
about the London riots model that we've
been we've been building okay
posture here ok yeah so I'm just going
to tell you a bit about an example of a
model that we've been building a sound
table so this is a sort of ongoing proof
of concept model of the London riots
that happened in 2011 so this is kind of
a good example to show the capabilities
of agent-based modeling so you've got
kind of a system which involves a lot of
agents these items hug behaviors and you
kind of have behavior arising out of the
individuals which is so it emerges out
of the behavior of lots of individual
people so this kind of kind of system
that we want to explore using
agent-based modeling so in this model
will have two kinds of agents we have
writers and police and these agents are
interacting with each other so that's
kind of a typical kind system you want
to use this particular form so it's give
you some just some context i'm sure
everyone's very familiar with what
happens so in 2011 there were widespread
protests in london following the
shooting of my god and local police and
these protests turned violent and then
led to widespread rioting throughout
london and then they spread to various
cities throughout England as well and
something some statistics there about
the extent of the damage and the writing
yeah sort of so obviously this was a
huge event and there's a lot of interest
in kind of understanding what was going
on you know like how we can do better in
the future in terms of dealing with
these kind of events and so yeah so
we've so our model is kind of most much
trying to understand you know the sort
of fundamental reasons why this kind of
thing happens but looking at the
dynamics of how something like this
spreads and how different for example
policing strategies might cause it to
evolve in a different way so this work
was based on a scientific paper which
was which came
jun 2013 by Toby babies and Hanna Frey
or about the UCL and they developed this
mathematical model of the London riots
and also the policing yes I just
explained its humble to you bet and so
this was a mathematical model in which
the behavior of writers and of police
was kind of you encoded in in our
particle equations and these assaults so
it's quite new just placed on some quite
simple assumptions about people pay get
and so you have so as assumed that's
because in this in these riots most of
the activity was a large retail site so
that's kind of what they base it on so
you have a map of London and the largest
retail sites in London you know are the
potential right sites and you have
agents throughout the city and they will
look around other nearby retail sites
and if there's a large site and also be
attractive to them and they'll also try
and go to places whether / that's
already occurring and where the writers
on outnumber police the basic have
motivation people have is to go
somewhere where they can write and
they're not very likely to be arrested
and also that people from water private
areas and we're waiting to rise because
obviously what is what was observed and
then also you have the police so the
police basically will just move around
the city to places where all over LA
riots are happening and arrest people
and try this past them and using this
simple model they were actually able to
broadly reproduce the geographical
distribution of the disorder so the kind
of so that's kind on the map
top there just like different parts of
how much writing happens in them and
also the specific resale sites where
there were large amount of disorder so
for example they started small wires in
a few different retail sites and and see
what happens in the model and in Clapham
Junction for example a very large riot
whereas in these other sites which in
there by the pizzas are very quickly and
kind of what drives that is the the size
of the retail sightings of proximity to
a large number of people from deprived
areas so our aim was to build an
agent-based model kind of inspired by
this works of encoding the same kind of
assumptions but allowing us but by using
agent-based modeling it's kind of a bit
more to modular we can like explore lots
of different scenarios quite easily
rather than having to like write down
the equations you know so we have an
environment which in this case is London
it sounds like a spatial model and in
that environment we have writers through
a puddle of spatial location in the city
and write sites they also have a spatial
location and then additionally the
police yeah so we have about 12
thousands potential writers and about a
thousand police the simulation runs over
48 hours with each time step being an
hour and the basic way that it works is
writers first of all police will move to
sites which have the most writers I'll
make arrests and then potential rioters
will make their decision of what to do
so this involves looking around them at
all the sites that are nearby and the
number of writers and police at each
site move it and then depending on what
the situation is that will say well
drive or not and also which sites to go
to take they do
so in addition to the both of us which
were kind of what made up the the
academic model that we were basing this
on we put in a few extra effects to kind
of look at different scenarios and tons
of police strategy and also media so one
is that it's going to take place a
certain amount of time to travel through
the city and as sort of observed to be
quite an important factor in how
policing and rice works how quickly
respond to new information you think
that happening in city so and police can
take a certain amount of time from when
they want to go somewhere to actually
write there another effect we consider
is the media so in in a model we place a
song everybody police islands writers
has perfect information about what's
going on everywhere which is not very
realistic so we can also put in an idea
of media so in the spirit of knowledge
so we can do this in two ways one
matlacha chemical social media is that
people who are writing people who are
out in the city can send out messages
about what's happening so I'm kind of
lets everyone know that the place that
there are at this much writers this may
be police and that might encourage more
people come on your cell broadcast media
which is that there's a large right
happening then the news might cover the
coverage so then at one point
that was the contract ok so I'm just
going to show you open / model we just
try that
yep so this is the curve and dashboards
we have visualizing what happens in the
model so here we have map of London
which is wearing a long time takes place
and because I go up here we're just
going to show the total activity what's
going on in the model so the yellow line
will be a yellow line showing total
number of people writing and a red line
shown total number of police officers
and on the map you'll see right isn't
police kind of moving around so you'll
have yellow circles representing the
number of writers at a site and red
circles representing the number of
police so I'll just run this so this is
kind of the first version i'm going to
show you is kind of a version which is
like waters in the paper where you have
birthings information and the police can
move your arms sort of immediately okay
then starts you have some beef where up
various some sites for mostly in the
more deprived areas which are darker
colors and then please could deal with
it very quickly you just get occasional
flops it's not goes on
ok
okay so now i'll show you imagine why we
have to flag in the police response
again we start with a long fire up but
it takes a little longer to get there so
that the initial kind of event is larger
and then also it takes longer for the
police are kind of quiet things down
because as people arrested then stop
just go to with you disorder will spike
on the sites then please conta me to get
that so there's a kind of gradual
tailing off over there's an oscillation
as time goes on
finally I'll show you the version what
we have this kind of social media effect
so in this case people don't have
perfect information what's going on the
only way they can find out is by other
people who already out there sending
messages out and telling people what's
going on
so in this case this really happens down
the total amount of activity that occurs
because people just only because of oil
what's going on and you see this unit
with a lot of very small advance but
very rarely you just go to slide you get
a much bigger one as it comes something
attracts more attention in the media and
yeah so uber moment as I say this is
still quite a civ proof of concept so
moving forward we really want to be able
to validate this model against real data
as I should see how accurate it is and
so that we can could have had some
confidence that we kind of broadly
capturing the main effects or what
drives this kind of thing so we could
use that for that we could use for
example data on the geographical spread
the disorder horizontal locations of
arrests and where people came from where
they were arrested the nature of the
crime and also police numbers writer
numbers so you can kind of you know try
and match up main facts and then once
we've done that we can then start to
explore counterfactuals so what would
have happened if police had responded
differently than they did hold that have
affected the way that the disorder went
on okay so that comes you just put your
mind is how the information is the first
example so then everyone does has
perfect information
okay yeah so just to add to that thanks
Fred just to say you might wonder how
would that be used how would that kind
of tool be used so we think about it but
it could be using number ways so first
of all you up so you want to get up to a
point where you're confident with it and
you can gather you know using data and
using kind of getting experts views on
it and that type of thing so you might
for example you might use it as a
training tool so you could use with with
with police and look at how how you
respond and look at the different ways
of strategy and look at how you know
things evolved so it's that and then of
course on top of that you can use it as
a planning tool so that's how we think
about it we think that you know you're
bringing together a lot of assumptions a
lot of understanding about this type of
phenomena and the dynamics and it could
be used as a planning tool so you
wouldn't be using it if the London riots
if some potentially you know happened
something like this happened again you
wouldn't pull this tool in and say okay
what's going to happen tomorrow it's
much broader than that you'd be looking
at you know for training in for planning
so it's we think about it is a you'll be
explicit about your assumptions you're
being explicit about what you know and
you know this is not per tunity to kind
of explore that and obviously a low-cost
kind of virtual environment okay so I
want to just touch on something else
that we're doing so you know our data
scientists you know big Python Easter's
they love you know using the tools i'm
using the notebooks we've also been kind
of looking at luigi pipelines to help us
with some of the calibration pipelines
and deployment and what we end up kind
of on this journey is we've end up
building a platform which we use to kind
of do collaborative agile data science
and we think that it's interesting and
you know we've integrate the notebooks
and we've buying a number of services
around that so we've actually written a
white paper about this that kind of has
a view on how we see data science
evolving and also talking about this
this platform so if you're interested
check it out we've yeah hop on up on the
site so to summarize we use modeling
switch or understand behavior and
helping us design policies for behavior
change lickable to strategic type of
problems so again you wouldn't use it
for solving kind of tactical tactical
problems and we use it you know we
simulate we use simulation for exploring
counterfactual even exploring kind of
future what if scenarios you know with
we're starting to think about how we can
package these up as data products and
yeah finally you know the Python data
stack is crucial to to our work and
we're yeah we do building developing
this platform around that to help our
guys work effectively so yeah thanks and
if you're interested in finding out a
bit more it's a great Makar North have a
great paper from the winter simulation
conference and Scott Scott pages course
and Coursera is really good about model
kind of model thinking thank you Thomson
frets if you have questions yeah so the
sensitivity the sensitivity of the
models do you repeat the question as
well for the purposes of the recording I
can so if you change inputs so the
question is really if you change the
inputs what kind of impact as I have on
the outputs so yeah very much a classic
kind of sensitivity analysis type of
thing um yeah will depend I mean we do
we do try to explore the models to
understand that because I mean once you
know models can get quite complex and of
course that's part of the kind of
difficulties you're putting in these
simple rules but as things start to
interact you can get a lot of effects so
we do try to explore the models and
understand that and that's sort of one
of the outputs that you'll you know one
of the jobs of building the models is to
understand that how sensitive they are
just slight changes I mean that's kind
of what we focus on the broader you know
giving I mean they'll be uncertainty I
mean effectively when this stochastic
elements of these models were doing
monte carlo simulations so you know
there's uncertainty there and randomness
so we need to take account for as well
so we try not to focus on you know this
number by understanding broadly
depending on how come from we are
depending on how much data is calibrated
to we won't be very certain about the
numbers so we have to take account for
that and also more than that just the
variation coming out as well especially
vice problem again imagine you come up
with a set of parameters that is what
happened lately now you're going to say
actually change the policy and cory's
couldn't cash in this would be about how
can guarantee that relation because
feedback loops yeah absolutely but
that's kind of why we wouldn't we
wouldn't use it as a tactical tool to
inform you know I mean feedback loops
everyone has that problem right I mean
it's yeah so I mean definitely we
wouldn't we wouldn't want to make claims
about we wouldn't calibrate it to an
unfolding scenario and say this way it's
gonna go I mean again agent-based
bowling can give you a model that's
sufficient but not necessary so in the
sense that we can give you a hypothesis
about what's going on but you know we
can't tell you what happened I mean
right I mean who you know it's bad yeah
my previous interest evolutionary
algorithms and this or thing i know i
mean you know I'd say there's a metaphor
that there's some you know overlap but
but I mean you know da SME is very
adaptable you can use them in a number
of different ways I mean I suppose but
yeah not really not really not really
sorry what that process or process was
for coming up with that he wasn't
yeah something off with the people
behaving this way yeah I mean we you
know we if you want to get kind of round
the statistical route I mean we've
focused more on explanatory to have a
modeling right than the predictive
modeling I mean I think for us
predictive elements is a good check so
if I theory you know if our theory is
strong and valid it should have some
should be able to predict you know have
predict some predictive power it will
depend I mean we do we also talked about
kind of theoretical models versus data
driven models so on the theoretical end
you know we'll work with people who may
don't have any data but what they want
to do is do a study of bringing together
what is known what is understood and
being explicit about that and bringing
that together and yeah so will it will
depend so that's on the one extreme the
other extreme will be more data-driven
and then you know it's also about I mean
is as much as like in in feature
engineering a machine learning you know
you there will be an exploratory phase
where you're figuring out what is kind
of hypothesizing about what is relevant
to the domain what factors are important
and it's a good starting point so it
will be it will be similar to that yeah
design sir yeah yeah
yeah I mean sorry so game theory how
relevant is game theory I'm not an
expert in game theory I had you know
understand very little of it really but
a game theory would be one kind of
theory and understanding about how
people behave I think we we don't try to
we try to be more we don't really adopt
much game theoretic kind of concepts I
think was probably I'm not an expert but
it's quite a trend away from that kind
of thinking and thinking more you know
and as data as we're collecting more
data about what people actually do we're
trying to model kind of closer to that
and away from the kind of assumptions
underlying came through if that makes
does that make sense yeah cool perhaps
one last question before we close can
imagine that you're a little a lot of
progress a lot of peoples and the output
is based on the water pronto simulation
we're going to see used to actually my
tune those robbers you just yeah we well
we we have used enough tried a number of
things over the years I mean we we tend
to you know working with Python and
working in a highly this is highly
iterative right highly iterative highly
agile so we will rather than spend a lot
of time focusing on finding the optimum
for some particular problem I think our
data scientist understand that even if
they were to spend the computational
power to find that up next week it may
not be relevant anymore so we're very
cautious and how kind of how much we how
we socially that they're often kind of
multi-objective optimization problems as
well so we'll have you know number of
criteria the macro level and it will
also be training kind of at the micro
level as well if we have that level of
data we tend to use I mean pretend to
use just sampling Latin hypercube
sampling to get a good broad view we
don't really do much kind of
goal-directed kind of optimization we
have used we have used some genetic
algorithm type techniques in the past
but we found that the cost of kind of
running them has been it hasn't value
were getting from finding that solving
that particular problem hasn't hasn't
always been worth it because the models
are changing and iterating so quickly if
that makes sense yeah
lovely walk will finish it that you
around for the whole weekend i am yeah
nowhere yep thomas a favorite both PS
you haven't what do Astley soon thank
you very much